chez-nous l'association des économistes
recommandent au gouvernement du québec
d'étendre ses prévisions budgétaires sur
20 ans avec le vieillissement de la
population et les investissements
d'infrastructure le gouvernement doit
être vigilant et transparent yves st
maurice et président du comité des
politiques publiques de l'association
bonsoir fonction des prévisions sur 20
ans pourquoi ces provisions se sauver à
temps parce qu'on était en période de
transition démographique
on sait que la démographie ça prend du
temps que ça se transmettent dans
l'économie donc on veut analyser voir la
transition économique qu'est ce que ça
va avoir comme pression sur les finances
publiques à la fois sur les revenus
parce qu'on certaine croissance plus
faible au cours des prochaines années à
cause du vieillissement la population et
de l'autre côté voir des dépenses de
santé qui vont donner les pressions sur
les finances publiques donc on est moins
sûr que le gouvernement projette sur dix
à vingt ans c est qu il est financier
pour voir un peu les pressions qui va
s'exercer sur les finances publiques en
ce moment on est sur cinq ans oui on est
sur cinq ans et on serait capable
d'aller à 20 ans je pencherai sur les
capacités au ministère des finances de
faire ça ou on fait des hypothèses ça me
dit que c'est ce qui va se réaliser
c'est juste de voir un peu est ce que la
transition démographique vaut vraiment
exercer des pressions
on peut faire des hypothèses et à tous
les ans tous les deux ans on peut revoir
un peu où est-ce qu'on a amené remettre
à jour voix est ce qu'on a dans bonne
direction oui ou non est ce qu'on peut
mettre actuellement des mesures en place
qui vont faire en sorte qu'on voit
limité finalement les pressions futures
sur les finances publiques
c'est un peu ce qu'on veut travailler en
fait ça se fait déjà la charge quelqu'un
finances publiques chez vous que le fait
donc c'est faisable on pose des
hypothèses et on voit un peu qu'est ce
qui se passe dans le futur
est-ce que c'est au ministère des
finances de faire ça ou comme je le
mentionnais je parlais du directeur
parlementaire du budget à ottawa le
bureau du budget au washington est ce
qu'on devrait y en avoir une entité à
part comme ça en fait tout à fait ça
fait longtemps que l'association
d'économistes le
le réclame d'avoir un directeur
parlementaire du budget ou autres états
a fait escale y est tout simplement
donc ce tracteur est d'ailleurs une
motion unanime adoptée à l'assemblée
nationale pour que les mecs soient
nommés et ça pour être au travail je te
demande de ce directeur parlementaire du
budget alors de faire des analyses à
long terme sous des finances ce serait
une analyse donc dite indépendante
oui tout à fait alors vous parler
d'investissements santé du
vieillissement de la population les
infrastructures aussi l'enjeu est
complexe sur les infrastructures
effectivement c'est un élément qui nous
préoccupe davantage cette fois ci on a
constaté par exemple c'est un petit peu
complexe mais je me suis posé
d'expliquer un bon exemple
au fait on fait un plein d'infos sur dix
ans un peu le plan québécois des
infrastructures et on regarde les
déficits de maintien d'actifs ça veut
dire que on regarde quels seraient les
investissements pour maintenir les
infrastructures publiques actuelles à un
niveau acceptable et seuls les
investissements ont augmenté l'année
passée de 6 milliards de dollars et on
regarde les investissements qui ont été
faits sont de l'ordre de 3 milliards
donc on voit que on aurait dû investir 6
milliards alors qu'on a investi 3
milliards pour remettre à jour les
infrastructures à niveau
donc on a comme un déficit de 3
milliards et si on fait ça tous les ans
mais ça risque à cause du problème d'un
futur on essaie pourtant de rattraper
lui investissements bancaires du passé
exactement exactement ça donc on
voudrait le gros manseng peut savoir
exactement qu'est ce qu'on a besoin
d'investir pour remettre toutes les
infrastructures publiques un niveau donc
à crise années ont fait de nouvelles
inspections qui font augmenter davantage
de déficit de maintien actifs donc on
demande au gouvernement d'avoir une vue
plus sérieuse de d'ensemble des
infrastructures publiques de ce qu'il
faudrait mettre à niveau et de faire un
plat sur le long terme sur dix ans de
résorption justement de ce difficile de
maintien là donc les investissements
qu'il faut pour remettre à niveau tous à
vous recommander aussi d'augmenter la
productivité de l'appareil
gouvernemental
ça veut dire quoi oui en fait on en fait
un processus qu'on éléments qu'on
demande à tous les a fait se dit heureux
de continuer le processus de
réévaluation des programmes
de revoir les processus comme terrain de
ma peau aux travailleurs du secteur
public de travailler plus fort on pense
que l'art visant certains processus je
pense qu'on peut augmenter de beaucoup
la productivité au niveau de l'appareil
et vous abordez également dans vos
recommandations prébudgétaires belgique
s'en vient au mois de mars
vous abordez dans votre apport de
questions d'éco fiscalité oui c'est
l'écofiscalité on trouve que c'est un
élément important aussi
on sait que les objectifs de réduction
des gaz à effet de serre sont quand même
assez assez important est assez
ambitieux on a déjà des moyens
actuellement au québec on à la bourse
carbone que lon marché du carbone donc
ça fonctionne bien
sauf que je vends il va falloir
programme a donné un coup de pouce à ce
marché du carbone va donc probablement
utilisé l'écofiscalité ce qui veut dire
taxer les mauvais comportements
donc si on veut réduire les gaz à effet
de serre et si on dit que le transport
privé est l'élément majeur qui produit
des gaz à effet de serre donc il faudra
taxer le transport privé que ce soit par
les péages ou par l'essence ou parle
l'étape sur les grosses cylindrées etc
on donne pas de suggestions mais on y va
falloir parlement taxer ces éléments là
pour changer les comportements pour
réussir à changer comportement est
l'élément important qu'on rajoute c'est
qu'il faut que que l'éco-ptz qualité
soit neutre fiscalement ces questions
récolte de l'argent au niveau des coûts
fiscalité il faut leur donner aussi la
population par la suite pour encourager
les bons comportements
oui donc on est pas le problème du
déficit zéro de l'équilibré budgétaire
avec ça non en fait on d'une note
fiscales dont une taxe de côté non
remettre l'autre côté pour encourager
les bons comportements
il sait maurice merci beaucoup ça m'a
fait plaisir merci bien au revoir